right now
he thinks everybody's smoking dope
celebrating his [ __ ] birthday that
egomaniac that's what he thinks
he's probably up there right now [ __ ]
going look at all these people
celebrating my [ __ ] birthday he
doesn't know it's just a small select
the [ __ ] confused
people and [ __ ] he's just men that
jesus stole some [ __ ] old
neighborhood somewhere what's happening
baby boy
nothing churchill what's happening now
people thank you for coming
april 20th the day the devil was buried
at sea stuffed in a garbage can
taken out fed to the sharks god knows
what the [ __ ] happened to him [ __ ] the
devil what's up brother how was your
weekend great i had a uh
a great weekend uh paula is
uh in the middle of law school finals so
i saw her thursday night
um
and then
we just yeah we just kind of hung out it
was fun so she got one more year left
after this year yeah she got one more
when she graduates next june or whatever
uh yeah she graduates in like may and
then she has to study for the bar
and when is the bar
it's like it's late summer i think i
think it's like come along she studies
for the ball yeah you bad [ __ ]
you'll be helping the quiz cards and
[ __ ] i don't know if i'm gonna see her
to be honest see you'll figure out a way
little holy [ __ ]
anyway i want to thank the houston
improv and the city of [ __ ]
houston surrounding areas for great
shows this weekend we had some great
times from bobby and his beautiful
girlfriend to [ __ ] hooky spooky
to all the rest of the [ __ ] church
savages were there at heart it was a
great houston's
still a great city but it's it's
something's happening across the country
statewide that i uh nationwide
that i see it [ __ ] traffic has
doubled in that city really yeah traffic
is [ __ ] horrendous man
traffic has doubled or tripled in austin
you know i haven't been in dallas in a
while but it's a
it's [ __ ]
boggling that
everywhere you go now it's bumping the
bumper bumping the [ __ ] bumper i
wonder what it is i wonder if maybe gas
prices so everyone is closer to the
ocean people moving to texas because of
the oil you know there's working tech
you know people chasing work right now
in this country yeah
so they go where the workers i don't
know maybe it's that you know you go to
san jose there's a little bit of traffic
sacramento's got a little bit of traffic
you go to the big cities there's a lot
more people so it's bumper-to-bumper no
matter where the [ __ ] you go you know i
always wondered what that was like
because i i really had three choices
stay in boston
go to la or new york those were my three
options i've always wondered how like
if i went to
university bu boston university
had a business degree and just like
sent
applications all around the country and
then what if i got a job in missouri
like one of my one of the kids i went to
high school with
got a job at churchill downs
he's from [ __ ] sudbury now he's at
churchill downs doing like i.t i'm just
like that must be kind of weird at least
i knew i was coming to l.a or new york
everywhere else it's just like i'll go
anywhere so your question is what if you
would have gone somewhere else
completely different well not even just
that i actually know what i was thinking
of and this is kind of interesting
um
when i interned out here the summer
hold it before i went to new york
and then once i got to colorado
i think i bought another gun maybe uh
in 86.
i bought a gun from some kid on the
street that looks like a friend of a
friend and i always think about that
that's my biggest what ifs
like how i carried a [ __ ] gun well
how confused and dumb i was to carry a
gun all those years it must i can't even
imagine but it must have like
like doesn't it add stress to your life
like cause you just walk because you
just you must know it's there it's there
you know it's there oh my god
you feel
it wasn't that i had a little dick
syndrome
it was just that i always thought that
was my fate
so i didn't want to be without one what
are you looking at lee what is this
nothing eastern died but i got back on
jesus christ there's always this
confusion we i like that when you only
had one [ __ ] scream it's like you you
know you you're sending a rocket ship to
[ __ ] nasa i'm like after the moon
but i always think of that and there's a
lot of people that do [ __ ] yeah have
uh guns that carry i mean how [ __ ]
lucky i was that i never got really
pulled low with a gun on me like a cop
never found i was never in a possession
of a firearm nothing
nothing one time i got chased with the
gun i threw it out
and i thought the cop saw it he didn't
[ __ ] see it
and i learned what people see and what
they don't see you know
so you went to jail in colorado
and it was unlucky
that you got caught in in theory i know
it turned your life around but
how many do you go did you get unlucky
more or lucky more because it seems like
lucky yeah i'm very lucky wow i feel
like i'm very very lucky because
that colorado thing
i mean at the end of the day there was
nobody untarnished i mean i can't say
that i don't know what velo went through
i don't know what tidwell went to i know
what i went through and i'm telling you
that this was none you know nobody got
hurt nobody
but
it could have happened later on in my
life when somebody got i'm happy
that it happened then and it really
slowed me down i think about
i'm coming up on uh
i don't know what the [ __ ] of this
anniversary at 32 years when i left
north bergen the first time like when i
really left and said i'm not [ __ ]
coming back here
i'm gonna try to get my life together
before i created chaos like i left on
like medium
terms
for colorado i only loan shark money
i owe this bookie like 800 bucks
i mean nobody was really
influen like nobody i had a couple
people pissed off at me but i didn't
know where they stood there was rumors
you know what if i would have stayed
that year
you know what if i never would have sent
the tape to adam sandler
for the
shot you know do you ever but think
about stuff that you didn't do like
like uh things you could have gone out
for they didn't go out for oh absolutely
like something someone talked you into
no i like not going to the blood test
for the [ __ ] marines that morning
what if i would have went to the blood
trash for the marines that morning
you know would have been a lifer would i
would have would i gonna gone to the
marines and pulled the rich gear and got
in trouble for shining shoes and got
thrown out of the marines i mean what
this is what your life becomes and you
think of what made you make the
decisions and some people go crazy i
just move on with it right i leave it to
fate you know like sometimes you just
[ __ ] get involved in something you
know i had an audition this morning and
i got to tell you something these people
called me in four times for this [ __ ]
movie
and i didn't want to [ __ ] go in for
it i had my reasons i just didn't feel
it just didn't feel right and i went
there and i had a great time at the
[ __ ] audition you know would i take
the film i don't know it's going to be
in my busy busy busy time
and i don't but what if i wouldn't have
gone in for you know
these nights i put my jiu jitsu knee
pads on in my jujitsu pants i'm like
i don't know if i can go to jiu jitsu
and i i think of something i think every
time i do go to jiu jitsu how much of a
good time i have and in the middle of
the class even though i'm sweating
and i'm breathing and i'm huffing and
puffing and i think i'm gonna die i say
to myself jesus christ i'm happy i can't
just so i learned a pretty [ __ ] cool
move yeah
so
in other words you don't you never want
to uh live a life of whatevs
but there's always gonna be what if
because you could go the other way
like what if
i was something but if you went to
and then
i don't know there was an earthquake or
like that that's there's always
something that could happen on the other
side well you don't think about it that
way i i never wanted the biggest
question mark i never wanted in my life
was what if i didn't do it
what if i always thought that
early on i knew that i was
don't this is nothing to feel good about
but i always knew that i was the type of
person
it's like when i kick work away
when somebody offers me a weekend
somewhere i don't like turning it down
because i know
somewhere in the future i'm gonna need
that money right i'm gonna go why did i
turn that particular gig down i'm one of
those guys you know
but
that's what i didn't want to do in my
life i talked to a lot of people i had
one friend in particular who
you know she
she uh
sold
her life out for alcohol and we we all
know people listening to the show
we've all seen those people that have
great opportunities and have sold their
life out for alcohol or dropped or blow
you know when you when we were talking
yesterday on the drive
we were talking about that i saw a few
people in houston that
were funnier comics than i was
they had
more
i mean they had so many things going on
in their career that i wish i would have
had
and they blew it for [ __ ] alcohol or
coke or
and i think about myself what made me
stop at 44 but even though
i was doing blow i was always making
strides
you know and i made little strides and i
never went backwards even though i was
doing blow it was like the blow was my
own personal problem
i turned it into a personal problem
as opposed to in my mind i did let's
let's be honest in my mind
when you have a problem it carries over
into all the other avenues in your life
okay okay when you have a problem doing
something
you know i have a friend that won't
return calls
and she has a ton of problems in her
life if she would just return calls and
start with that the problems would
disappear every time i talk to her
there's a [ __ ] dilemma
every day that i talk to her once a
[ __ ] every 10 days there's always a
problem in her life
but the biggest problem is she doesn't
do she doesn't take care of little
problems
if you take care of little problems the
big problems with themselves out
somewhere you know there's little things
to start with little things
you know
that was always my biggest fear lee
it wasn't when i got into all right
let's talk about stand-up comedy when i
got into stand-up comedy i got to stand
up comedy not knowing what i really
wanted to do i was just looking for
something different there was a hole in
my life that i was looking for that had
to get filled in more ways than one
it wasn't just about a career or
whatever my career was a burglar my
career was a [ __ ] thief i had a
[ __ ] career that's what in my mind i
thought i deserved okay
then you've got
then after about a year or so you meet a
couple different types of comics you
make comics that are like uh
bill burr and then you meet comics that
are like todd jordan you know todd
jordan is i've heard the name i think no
you don't know who he is you heard the
name from me okay he's a comic from
denver that was a high-level comic in
denver and that was it
that's where it ended you know and
there's for every 22 bill burrs or
sebastian maniscalco's or doug benson
there's a thousand guys that are funny
in these guys
that just didn't have the oomph
to go over the hump mm-hmm
so it was funny because when i got
banned at the comedy works i would go to
the car i would take a bus from boulder
to denver and i'd go to the comedy where
it's like going to back tuesday night
was open mic night but what it really is
is the season comics come down and get a
few drinks
and talk [ __ ] in front of the young
comics about how they went out and this
and this and if you ever do this room
and then you sit there salivating like i
can't wait to go on the road someday you
know
but these guys would downplay it okay
but when i was in the room with them
colorado regent would have like let's
say
you know new mexico
arizona
uh wyoming that's what borders colorado
you know if you look at the map i don't
know i don't have it right in front of
me right now
so these comics would just work that
that area right they would work for
tribble in those days they would work
for the last chains which was new mexico
tucson
and colorado springs
and they also worked for like uh uh
the book of the dome to suck my dick the
one that booked me in texas and wanted
me to go to new mexico they worked for
that guy they worked for a guy named
david tribble
who's a great book by the pacific
northwest nice guy he's missing in the
end i don't know how he lost it
but he's a great [ __ ] guy
you never asked how he left and then
after that that's your main area in
kansas and they would go to kansas city
whatever club was in kansas city and
that's what they would work and i
remember going back and i don't want
people to judge me on this i'm just
telling you how i thought and i remember
i would go back there and listen to
these guys think
and i would sit there and go so they're
doing a lot more than i'm doing that's
all they're doing
that's all they're doing these guys
don't strive to be on television they
don't strive to write they don't strive
to do comedy on the road and when i
started comedy with so many more stand
up comedy shows on tv a and e even had
one comedy on the road and they would go
to different stand-up comedy clubs and
each comedy club would have like a
contest to see what four comedians would
go on that show oh hey and he had one
vh1 had one mtv probably had three
stand-up cops yeah like what happened
blend all these stations had all this
comedy but there was a lot more comedy
on television so
the level of comics that i saw at the
comedy works in those days weren't on
those tv shows so you have those level
of guys then you have the level of guys
that do the tv stand-up routines to
tonight's your blah blah
then you have the guys that do that and
do movies
you know i always wanted to be the guy
that would do it all like even back then
i'm like huh
kansas sounds nice for two times you
know wyoming sounds really nice to go
twice to do comedy but after that i'm
gonna expand my horizons there was this
one guy
excuse me that did like the san
francisco comedy competition he would do
punchlines i remember how they treated
him
they treated him like an outsider even
though he was very funny they liked him
but they didn't
he wasn't part of the [ __ ] cool
circle
because he was cooler than them do you
understand the cool people who aren't
cool right so i always knew like when i
got thrown out of the denver comedy
works as an open mic
i was very happy in a way and that's why
when i went back and i did that tour
with chappelle and i saw wendy curtis
who runs that i thanked her because at
the time when she threw me out there
were so many bad things going on in my
life but there was only one good thing
and that was calmly
i was keeping my life alive by doing
little sets here and there no matter how
bad i felt like no matter how bad i felt
about my daughter or the wife or what
was going on how broke i was or how i
was living in this little [ __ ] room
and i wasn't really feeling bad for
myself because at least i was doing blow
you know i'm saying i wasn't living how
i wanted to
at the age of 30 but at least what i
wanted was around me you know it's like
mick jagger says you don't get what you
want but you get what you need
but uh
i had so many little bad things going on
the only good thing was that i was
really pursuing comedy heavy duty like
since i had nothing going on i might as
well put my efforts into comedy and see
what happens with it
and what happened was i got better and i
improved
right so when she told me when they
threw me out for the sexual harassment
thing
yeah it was sad that they threw me out
and it was sad but i had to make a
decision i had to make the decision to
stay in denver and just work the other
rooms with the comedies
now everybody knows that the comedy
works is in a room listen man as a human
being as a person you always want to be
in that a clique
just because you know that you're going
to improve that much just by walking in
them being a part of that you're going
to grow as a human being and whatever
the profession is you know let's say you
want to be
a brick mason right
right and at this one company they'll
pay you 12 bucks an hour and they'll
kind of teach you right but if you go to
another company
you learn from old italian dudes and
these dudes have been doing 50 years
they'll pay you eight bucks an hour but
you learn how to lay brick the [ __ ]
old-fashioned way what would you do
a lot of people go for the money yeah
that's a tough decision but
guys like me would go to for the less
money to learn from the best that's how
i i like to like that time like that was
my mentality like yeah i'm going to go
to mckelvey's and what's in there like
[ __ ] sea rooms
what am i going to get from those guys
how to sell t-shirts on the show
how to [ __ ] sell cd you know it was
that mentality was that road mentality
like yeah man we just worked oklahoma
whatever not even oklahoma city like
they work like a [ __ ] suburb of a
suburb
and they're trying to fight even though
i'm going to oklahoma city i'm excited
i'm going for one night uh it's it's
that mentality i always thought there
was a lot more it's a hard decision
speaking of what we're just talking
about how about making decisions
and when you say it out loud like that
you know what decision you're supposed
to make but when you're broke 21 22 out
of school that three bucks or four bucks
extra an hour is sometimes too hard to
turn down
well it depends what you want to do with
your life i mean yeah i'm gonna get four
bucks an hour and they're gonna teach me
and you're going to pick up bad habits
if you really want to be a brick mason
i really wanted to be a comic
and i knew one thing i didn't want to
pull the louis lamar i didn't want to be
on the speed track and have to come back
and redo my act and learn again
i didn't want to con nobody when i i
knew this was for me i knew this was my
last chance to be a [ __ ] human being
i knew this in my heart at the time i
knew i had nothing i was going into my
[ __ ] 30s with nothing i own nothing i
had no possessions i just lost a
marriage i lost a child
i had a car i had a mattress i had some
[ __ ] clothes i had a little bit of
cash and this is all i had i lived week
to [ __ ] week bro don't think that i
was at 28 i was better than the other 28
year old but i knew that for me to grow
you want to be around the [ __ ] best
so i took a chance once they threw me
out of the comedy worship like again
what am i gonna do hang out in colorado
springs with those guys no
i picked up my car and i went on the
[ __ ] road and i don't mind hearing
about comics living in their [ __ ]
cars and just going committing to it
this is a commitment
this is when you know you even have
people that tell you they want to learn
how to edit and you check with them
three months later and they still
they've done one thing but you as an
editor know that they're missing it like
when people come talk to me and they say
i really want to do stand up i really
want to be funny man i need your help
and i'll just send them on one simple
mission
all right tomorrow down stage hit me
back after you get on stage let me know
how you did
if they don't hit me back they didn't
really want to do it right we've seen
that you know i have seen now people
starting podcasts
but then also the crazy i was telling
you the other day
i want that barry cat saying i went on
all those interviews i learned
even back when i was working in high
school interviews a lot of times will
cancel an interview a couple times
just to see if you're really interested
in the job if you're persistent enough
right absolutely i could see that but
he's busy call back next week and
schedule just to see absolutely [ __ ]
literally yeah leave it it's it's
you know i i i i know all the reasons
why when people come to me for anything
now i know the steps at this age if you
come to me and say you want to be an
electrician
yeah go do this
that's it it's simplified now it's right
in your hands listen you don't know
about something you go to the [ __ ]
library and use their yahoo and their
google right or wrong yeah but what do
you need a library card probably that's
it i don't know
yeah they haven't because the north
hollywood library they've got computers
in there yeah i go in there they get
books sometimes they got [ __ ]
terminals set up in there i mean they
got the i don't know how you can find
the book on a [ __ ] computer i mean
i'm still used to the dewey decimal
system with the [ __ ] books and you
got to write it down and go to the shelf
you know how to do that
i used to when i was a kid now i don't
now you have to go to the assistant and
ask if they have this book in stock and
she'll [ __ ] look right through it but
that was my biggest worry at least i had
was
not completing something i had
done so many incompletes oh my god
i'd started so many [ __ ] things and
quit you know i didn't think there was
significant enough but the reason why
you and i have seen it here in los
angeles especially
see
in los angeles
you have this level and you're and the
people could walk around and they're
able to touch that level like you're
able to bump into david spade or whoever
the [ __ ] you bump into
and it gives you i don't know
people want to start things
but when they what's the result of being
here being on television is being famous
is being a limo somebody opening up a
door for you people start things that
that doesn't happen in 90 days they go
on to the next mindfuck
yeah you know when i started the podcast
with you it wasn't to start a podcast to
become rich and famous in six [ __ ]
weeks i'm doing this till i [ __ ] die
yeah cause you i mean correct me from
wrong i know you had some sponsors on
beating the beast but not a lot nothing
like anything about money i wanted to do
it to get your word out there so people
know where the [ __ ] you're coming from
why keep bullshitting people yeah people
see you on stage and they say oh this
guy's a nice guy but i'm not a nice
[ __ ] guy i don't want to talk to you
about [ __ ] martians i'm not joking
like that i don't know about that [ __ ]
you know people come up to me and send
me [ __ ] uh my space [ __ ] oh look at
this bigfoot thing send it to joe i
don't give a [ __ ] about bigfoot i'm
gonna send this to joe i'm gonna delete
this [ __ ] thing
don't send me that [ __ ]
actually sorry that you stream went out
again um
do you ever think about it and look back
and maybe are glad you didn't get
something at a certain point because
today like i just did my first
consultation today and it went great
and i as i'm leaving here i was like huh
i wish i had started this a year ago
like when i first started doing this
full-time but then i was thinking about
like i learned so much the last year
about it
i probably would have not done a good
job at it and then just stopped doing
the business
and now after just only oh this is all i
did last year to make money this is the
only thing so i actually i like i feel
like it was good almost no this is what
you suppose this is the evolution look
we were talking about something today
and i don't want people to get this the
wrong way
how the [ __ ] i'm saying when i talk
about this i talk about how i felt
growing up when i was growing up
and i'd see
people who
had
whatever type of job i was impressed i
was impressed with barton jobs i was
impressed you work in the city as a
stock broker
you're a [ __ ] stock clerk or you know
you're a supervisor at some [ __ ] firm
or an attorney that always i always
loved that
but i'll tell you what i didn't like
i didn't like being at that place for 60
[ __ ] hours a week right and then at
the end of the year on top of all that
you had another problem lee
you have the problem that
you're [ __ ] making a ton of money for
somebody else
tons and they're giving you insurance
and that's it that's it if you go to
them and go listen i want to see what
you made last year i want to see what
this podcast made they're not going to
show it to you
they're not going to show it to you not
at all they're going to say this is what
we made and it has no concern with you
we pay you a salary you think when you
go into those editing people that you
worked for what do they charge the tv
exactly yeah well they charge a tv show
for them to pay you what they were
paying you what do you think they charge
the tv show
double triple that that
so after a while a guy like you goes
[ __ ] this you know what
i'm gonna hustle
man i got two kids man i got a wife man
i got this i got that
guess what that means your household's
gotta be your game's gotta be tighter
yeah you know that means on the first of
the month joey diaz lee syed a bunch of
[ __ ] started zero i started
zero the first a month everything that
pops up happens like i said to you today
if lax crashes tomorrow and the [ __ ]
the floor goes up with lax i can't fly
out of here can't fly out of burbank
what do i do at zero i got about let's
say they closed lax now for 60 days i
got to come up with a [ __ ] new
solution for 60 [ __ ] days i got to
feed my wife and my kid right
i'll put something together
that's called the hustle that's called
believing in yourself and i never
believed in myself in areas like being
good looking or being very [ __ ]
intelligent or being a tough guy and
shooting people i tell you where i
really believed in myself and putting
two things together like you want to put
something together only but we're going
to put it together the right way like i
was the type of guy that you come to me
and say i got three guys they want to
buy a half ounce of blow
well blow costs 1600 an ounce that means
they got to come up with a what they
give you
they gave me eight cash all right we
gotta we could buy that half ounce
they're gonna charge us nine and we're
not gonna make money so guess what we
gotta do we gotta come up with another
eight get that ounce to 16
and then we could cut it sell them and
we could make a ton of money what do you
say leave i only got 110 in my account
well i got 60. so get on that [ __ ]
phone
make some calls tell people that you
give them a grant for 85 bucks it's
usually 100
and bring over the [ __ ] money
and within an hour you'll get it for
blow you'll get it that's that's that's
hustling and next thing you know instead
of making fifty dollars and whatever you
made three bills in the grammar blow
and
you do you know when i first got here to
do coke i tell that stupid story about
the whitney houston thing
in those days
from 2000 to 2003 guys i did whatever i
needed to do to make the [ __ ] ends
meet when i first moved in with terry in
the back of my mind i couldn't let it
down i was living in her [ __ ]
apartment i couldn't let it down i kept
my little apartment over there but i was
still what am i gonna do come over here
and sleep in my wife's house and my
woman's house and not help her out
i paid her off i paid some months i'd
give a half and some months i gave her
the whole run some once i give her half
the [ __ ] rent in six months if she
gave me her car to take to auditions i'd
give her the [ __ ] car payment that's
my woman i gotta take care of it you
know what i'm saying i'm not gonna send
it to get a [ __ ] pedicure
you know if i don't have the money but
i'm gonna help her with her [ __ ]
bills a little bit and that's what i did
so i had to pay two rents basically
i had to pay child support i had to make
all these payments lee tell these people
how much i might check from the comedy
store 15 bucks 15 bucks a set you do
four sets in a week what's that add up
to 90 bucks 60 stupid oh and you have
amazon and let's say you got a main room
spot you get 60 of the door divided by
15 comics so you probably make another
150 [ __ ] dollars so what's 150 and
[ __ ] 60
210 so 210 times [ __ ] four
eight forty okay
i was playing two rents
blah
and a cocaine addiction on 840. joey how
the [ __ ] do you do that well during the
week felipe sparrows only barcelona had
a room they hate paid 40 a [ __ ] room
fly had a room for 50 60 bucks on the
weekends who doesn't have a room for 100
200
and the rest brother came from slinging
weed
and slinging blow
or gambling or putting a bet in for
somebody or sitting on somebody's bets
and hoping they [ __ ] lost and if they
win holding them off and borrowing from
peter to pay paul that's a complete
different other way to make a [ __ ]
living
and i know you had little jobs when you
first came to l.a like sometimes you
would i saw cigars yeah but i was
because i was i took an uber here
because i don't know if people can see
that or not but you're unwrapping
another chip too yeah um but i was
talking to the guy and he works seven to
four every day
and that's what nine hours a day and he
makes 800 a week he said
and i was like you gotta take two
hundreds off
with the gas and stuff but then i was
thinking because i did that a few times
i was feeling bad about it
and but now that i'm starting this like
it's
like you you did you stole coke and
stuff so you wouldn't have a job so all
you could do is comedy
i'm
like i'm not saying i want you to sell
coke that's not no but i'm just saying
you did it so that you could focus only
on one thing right and it's uh
it's it's hard to make that decision
because a because i get emails every day
now about about how
either people want to do it or people
just did it and it's terrifying
and it's a
it's a it's a crazy decision to make
like i i second-guess it at least three
times a day usually what not having a
job yeah sometimes well
you're giving up a lot
and what's the opposite of giving up a
lot gaining
so you're somewhere in the middle
this is what i thought
okay
let's put let's draw a card in the
[ __ ] table here
and some people might hang up after this
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do
i didn't have i flunked that i didn't
have the means or parents or whatever to
put me through college so i started
hustling
whatever i make ends meet was i making a
ton of money no but i didn't too bad
you know i knew how to keep my rent low
i knew how to
you know this was before i was an
economist or before i ever dreamed i
knew that if you made two grand a month
you couldn't spend a thousand for rent
not that things are going to happen you
just can't so you got to keep your rent
low so you got to keep it at four or
five you know if you sacrifice a car
that's why i always liked working close
by
because no matter what happens
you could always get to work
okay
yeah
uh
and then for some but guess what lee i
always found a way to get 180
to pay for six credits of [ __ ] stupid
community college
and i kept doing it i kept doing 383 i
did two semesters when i was in colorado
and i went back to jersey i even think i
took a semester at some i uh not itt
tech uh some school lot in hackensack
they have i took like the course out
there and something but i never even
claimed it then when i went back to
colorado i went back to ccm
whatever and then i went to boulder
and there's a continuing at school at
night across the university and
eventually they came to me and they said
you have to transfer blah blah and i did
lee
and i got to tell you it was [ __ ] fun
but it was different i wasn't 20. i
wasn't 18. i was 24 or 20 [ __ ] five
i was like 24. and i'm walking around
this campus as a [ __ ] like a freshman
you know whatever the [ __ ] you want to
call it and i was having a great time
lee and eventually
you know what i'll never forget like
taking like
now i had
i don't know maybe less than a year of
credits to take before i could actually
get a diploma
something i never thought i would ever
attain
especially since i got a [ __ ] ged and
then guess what happened to me but i got
hit in the head with a left [ __ ]
punch
and that punch said to me just like this
it was like listen
so you just got to college okay you're
not get you you're not
taking a bunch of loans out this isn't
costing you a nominal leg it's low
interest
you know i even took a loan at one time
bought a car and sold it and made like 4
thousand bucks and people on that back i
mean that's what i'm talking about
hustling you know that's iceland that's
hustling you know i had a friend who
would take school loans out
put it in the [ __ ] bank
take a bank book alone on the [ __ ]
thing linda oh please that's
old jew ingenuity which
people don't even have anymore take a
school loan out what's the percentage of
a school loan i remember probably not as
much three percent
right what's the percentage anybody know
on twitter when you take a school loan
out what's the interest rate they
[ __ ] blast you with
okay you think about that one lisa think
about that [ __ ] scam
huh that's a [ __ ] juice scam okay so
what's the national what's the [ __ ]
average uh
8.8 bump and 10-year yield means it's
gonna go right now it's 3.86 percent and
it's going to go to 4.66 so if you
borrow money from the bank what do you
gotta [ __ ] pay
what's the interest rate
average amount rate
here we go
um
the first one i can see is 7.6
right off the bat you made four [ __ ]
points
yeah
right off the mat you made four [ __ ]
points so it cost you three percent
which is [ __ ] who gods
who gots
so my buddy would take those loans okay
and put them in the [ __ ] bank book in
the bank okay and then he would take a
bank book loan on that
okay okay and he would take that thing
and buy a house
how crazy is that
okay so wait so he he would take the
student loan out right he would take
this too long and he would just pay the
three percent of that right he would put
in the bank account get interest on that
and then take a loan out to forget this
whole thing saying like because he had
this money in the bank right he was just
down he missed it okay
so he would borrow against it
i forget how you would make the [ __ ]
money see i'm half [ __ ] i ate a
couple [ __ ] edibles a couple but
that's the type of [ __ ]
that that you fart no not yet it's like
a [ __ ] fart in here it smells like
maple syrup when we first started yeah
it must be something left over in this
[ __ ] i heard you went to denny's
and got french toast no i don't need
that banana bread french toast no i
wanted to it's not bad it sounds good it
looks good did you see that my dad said
he had it that's what he said he said it
was great yeah it looks [ __ ] really
really good looks like i also give you a
[ __ ] heart attack also i'm sure but
that's that was the thing so
not to get off the subject let me tell
you what happened with this left hook
okay
i totally forgot about that what the
[ __ ] was i gonna do with this degree
once i got it
like this is
eight credits left i just got out of
prison
and i'm like
wait a second
so after i get this degree
what
the only person that's going to give me
a job
is somebody in new york that means i'm
going to move to new york get an
apartment
and take a train and brown bag it to
lunch
and start all over again at 20 whatever
the [ __ ] i am
when there's kids that are three years
younger than me already doing this job
they're gonna be smacking me around
bossing me around but here's where it
gets better lee because i didn't even
look at it as an option i didn't even
look at it as an option then i looked at
it as a jail sentence
that's it i'm gonna be an economist or
or [ __ ] be some like what i really
wanted to be was uh
yeah that's what i want to do economies
and i want to do like international
markets like that's what i want to do i
have because i could speak spanish but
that was it i'm going to travel and do
that and that's it
that's my [ __ ] life then i gotta
watch
that just destroyed my insides a watch
yeah when you retire they give you a
[ __ ] watch oh okay
jesus christ
so that was my fear right there that
this is what i'm stuck with until
whatever right you know for some people
it's marriage for some people for me it
was that this is what i'm gonna do every
day and then on the weekends i get
saturday and sunday off
and i get to [ __ ] mow a lawn and fix
my house up and take care of kids
so where's my [ __ ] piece where's my
day off where's my [ __ ] sitting
around and just floating naked in the
[ __ ] pool that's not gonna be in my
you know what i'm saying like that was
my biggest fear yeah so that's when i
started thinking of my [ __ ] careers
you know like what am i gonna do you
need something you need something you
need something with dependability i
wasn't looking i knew i wasn't
mental capacity to make a half million
dollars a year as a doctor or something
like that once i got the felonies i knew
so i had to make what works for me what
worked for me at the time
comedy
everything about it worked
i could run i could hide you know i had
just gotten divorced i had no credit
i i was [ __ ] shell shocked
and i just wanted to find myself at that
age
what better than to find yourself and on
the [ __ ] road driving smoking dope
listening to the radio
it's the best way to find yourself is to
drive and yeah
and that's what really [ __ ] happened
now what if
what if when i came to l.a and no agents
wanted to sign me
if i would have said you know what i'm
gonna just move back to colorado and do
some comedy from time to time
i think really in my heart comedy really
saved me because i think i would have
been in jail now if it wasn't for comic
[ __ ] or or you would have had an od
probably
or odd i'm like nah if i was an od i
would obviously just trust me i went
[ __ ] hard that's why i couldn't
understand when those comics let the
addiction beat them
like when i had an audition i prepared
the night before no matter how bad i
wanted to snort coke i wouldn't snort
coke tonight before don't get me wrong
there was a lot of auditions i didn't
give a [ __ ] about what i did snorkeling
i was gonna say not snorting coke for
you is probably like doing a little bit
of edibles it's just like oh my god he's
not more than anyone normally would lee
when i get a call like at six o'clock
and let's say in my mind all day he i
already had the money in my pocket to
buy blow
and i get a call not to you know to go
to an audition oh my god i would look at
the audition what time is that 2 20.
see in those days
i wanted auditions later on because i
get me even if i woke up at nine
and i got my head straight till 12.
i could learn the lines and go in there
at 2 3 o'clock so i still kept i could
still keep it together right but those
10 o'clock auditions like [ __ ] snort
because you could tell i snorted oh yeah
i don't i like it's a little bit back
but you've never really talked about it
like what was going through your head
when you were like yeah i should still
go to college
like that's still like i should still do
that like it just blows my mind that you
were taking classes as you were selling
coke and and robbing people and
being you
like you're like yeah i still need to
get that degree
i i just never really talked about it
i never shook it lee
i never shook it
i never shook it as much as i wanted to
not be that person
i love that side of me
i love that side to me that if if
things go [ __ ] bad i can just put a
gun to you or work you or
i loved that [ __ ] cold side of me at
the time you know the other night i went
somewhere and i had black sabbath on and
like what the [ __ ] do i listen to this
after 40 [ __ ] years
why the [ __ ] do i have volume 4
in my car after 40 [ __ ] years
listening to this [ __ ] i still like it i
mean i still giggle sometimes the songs
get me off and i'm driving you know why
i like it you know why i like it lee
because it takes me to a time
when my life was i couldn't control it
it was unconfusing
it was [ __ ] horrible so why do you
like that
as a reminder i guess
as a reminder how fast things could slip
up i guess in a way i don't know
i just at that time lee i wanted to be a
different person but there was something
that told me i would never be that
person so what am i even trying what the
[ __ ] is wrong i'm always going to be a
piece of [ __ ] dave i'm not going to
amount to nothing
that was my mentality like why am i
doing this why am i doing this trying to
do this when this is not gonna [ __ ]
ever pan out for me man
i'm gonna always be you know i was going
to school and i'd find myself in like a
study hall with like you know like a lot
of stuff like a library and i'd have to
go do something look a project up at
night or something and i'd be in the
library with let's let's just exaggerate
20 kids
and i'd look at these kids and i can't
lie you they were all
completely different than me
and they were all had been raised
completely different than i was and
that's all i could think about while i
was sitting in the study room with them
feeling [ __ ] so inferior to these
kids that were in this room and so
insecure that all these kids had parents
that all these kids maybe maybe other 20
kids in here maybe eight of them
smoke pot
the other ones are what society call
nerds who i don't hate at all by no
means but they were not me that's what
made me even feel worse that they were
nerds
because they were not on me so i never
really got
i i wasn't comfortable with my skin at
that time lee
so yeah i would go to college and you
know i would go to uh let me tell you
about a dumb thing i would do i would
sell cars how many times i would make
[ __ ] seven thousand a month some
months selling cars a minimum of [ __ ]
five grand
even when i went to chrysler plymouth
you know what i would do some days what
while i was working i'd say guys i gotta
go to dry cleaner and
they lost my shirt and they'd say okay i
take a demo and i'd shoot across the
street to the boulder mall and i go to
that store that engrave you things
you know the stores that engrave things
for you okay and like going in each they
have parker pens you know what parker
pen is just a nice pen i guess a nice
pen
and have all different colors and stuff
and cross
cross was another old pen i think they
still have been some stores
where uh it's just a nice patent they
have gold ones and silver ones
and i would rob those pens like i would
make the lady show me the pen
and then when she would turn her back on
me she'd leave the big drawer open and
i'd take six pens put in my pocket and
cross the street and go right back to
the chrysler plymouth store
and sell 10 pens for 10 bucks a piece
and get 60
now why would somebody who makes 5 000 a
month
do something risk everything he's got
for 60 [ __ ] dollars
to be a chump to [ __ ] be a chump only
i would do something like that at that
time
because it it it reminded me of who the
[ __ ] i was and where i came from
i i liked having that little thing and
it was my own little secret nobody knew
about
i would tell them how i know the chick
that works over there she steals them
gives them to me
give me 10 bucks a piece who takes 10
bucks for these [ __ ] things
i remember going to the university of
colorado in boulder one day and there
was like
a thing of like cheap watches like you
know those 39.95 watches i took the
whole rack
what how
i just picked how do you pick up a right
i picked it up and walked out of there
with it like i did michael's jeweler's
brother
why wouldn't you do something like that
and
embarrass yourself and your friends and
then you have to go answer your friends
that's the dumb [ __ ] i did it's not at
the same level at all but it's kind of
what's going on with like the aaron
hernandez thing and
all those like tiger woods all those
people who make
dumb mistakes like that
that's no it's
you're absolutely right
it's a complete different level but it's
that same theory it's the same theory
you're absolutely right that's how it
starts
it's just
but i still can't understand
getting seven million dollars a year
and going somewhere and shooting
somebody
now but let me tell you something
between me and you
at 28 and i'm gonna look you in the
[ __ ] face and tell you this and
you're gonna die at 28 if i had seven
million dollars i'd still would have
done drugs you know but i would have
done it in my house
yeah and that was just me i would never
be that makes sense i would never be on
i wouldn't be at nightclubs people would
not know my [ __ ] business
i'm one of those guys you know i i'm not
saying that i wouldn't have killed
somebody or whatever the [ __ ] by mistake
i mean we don't [ __ ] know the story
of why this idiot did this nobody ever
[ __ ] knows i mean i don't i don't
know right i never paid attention to the
trial what happened it's just he's the
most recent one who's done it but
there's tons of stories of just
idiots throwing away everything
it's like that ryan leaf guy like
there's tons of them
i just uh i i didn't understand where my
mind was then like the things
did you realize it were you like ashamed
of it or you just had fun i had no
reason to be ashamed of it because
nobody knew about it
but there was a kid that washed cars at
the [ __ ] uh chrysler plymouth place a
little young kid if i was 20 whatever he
had to be 21 and he had a cute little
blonde chick you know george reminded me
about this one day
and the kick kind of bothered me a
little bit he pissed me off one day
something about blow something
and at lunch time i just went i knew he
was there i knew he was at the
dealership and he wasn't leaving i went
to his house kicked the door down and
took all his blow and brought it back
that took him like three days to figure
out it was [ __ ] me
you know i really didn't give a [ __ ] i
lied my teeth out he told me he was
gonna get three people after me whatever
i told him go ahead i didn't rob your
[ __ ] house why would i leave here and
then he came to him and they goes you
know i thought about
what you're saying you're right you
would have never left here and robbed my
house
you know i got all this to lose why
would i rob your house in reality i did
go to his house
and i probably got you know four or five
[ __ ] grams what if i would have got
caught coming out of that
with the coke and breaking an entry
that's five [ __ ] years
with a criminal record for theft before
something like that and you didn't plan
it you it wasn't like it was at night
when like people wouldn't see you you're
just like hey it's noon time i would get
impulsive i used to be like very
impulsive let's pretend
me and you were tight for a while let's
pretend that you and i
were tight and we were doing coke deals
and i bought coke from you and you
really dug me
and i really dug you blah blah blah
okay
uh
somewhere along the line
i went to your house one night
and
you had a little bit of a [ __ ]
attitude towards me in those days
and by the time you come back like lee
you've been selling this this for 500
the whole time well i had to raise my
price and you guys are selling and
doubling the money on me and now
okay
i would probably come back with the
money and pay you what you want but
you're on the robbery list now
we got you on the list now trust me
we're gonna keep doing business with you
but we're gonna wait till you put your
guard down and it's gonna be the saddest
[ __ ] day of your life
and that's what i would do
[ __ ]
and i'd wait till i i'd call a bar one
night and it was i was the luckiest guy
in the world
because i would just happen to call
let's pretend lee hung out at swanees
and there was a bar called joe's and i
hung out at lenny's
something and you were at swanees and
all of a sudden you said you know i'm
gonna take a walk over to joe's and you
went over to jose and called me
and i said to you what's going on and
you said where you at and i said i'm
over at lenny's
where were you over at joe's like who's
over at whatever's with you and you'd
say me and this guy pete i go
pete the wench yeah
who's he with and you tell me who he's
with i go to stay there
when they ask you who called tell him
you got to call your mom and ask her
what she wanted okay
guess where i would go where the pizza
has to rob because i knew he was at the
bar with you
this is way before cell phones this is
way before
pagers this is way when you did
everything on a whim so if i know is he
comfortably is he sitting down does he
have money on the bar
yes he does he's got a girl with him
done he's getting robbed
because he just put his guard down he
didn't take care of his business on a
friday night he's a coke dealer he
shouldn't be at the [ __ ] bar that's
how treacherous i was like i just wait
i'd give you time because i knew as a
drug dealer you're gonna [ __ ] up
on a friday night you just got your load
you just got it you didn't sell it all
you just got your [ __ ] package right
so that means that you're you what are
you doing out that means there's got to
be a package hidden somewhere
do you find that political so let's say
i call lee and go go over there and ask
him if he's got power he'd go no he's
getting powered around 11. he says the
guy's going to meet him at his house at
11.
if you see him out at 130
he said he's done i'm taking that
package because i know it's somewhere
even if he sold half of it the rest of
that package got to be somewhere
it's crazy it's [ __ ] crazy like
so i would just put you on a mental list
and just have you there
instead of going after you or robbing
you right away no no no no no
i do business as usual like you didn't
even do nothing to offend me
and i'd tell a friend i had like my
friend glenn conti a ferny
i tell one of those guys guess who's
getting around next
who and i tell them they go that oh i
knew you were gonna say him [ __ ] him
he's getting cocky yeah he's gotta go
and we give him like three or four weeks
and one night
i'll call one of my friends and they go
guess who's at the [ __ ] bar he's
[ __ ] up and he's talking about he just
picked up a kilo who lee
keep him there that's like a weird
action movie like an answer
and we would shoot to his house
listen sometimes we'd have an opening a
window
i'd have a glass cutter with [ __ ]
whatever no you wouldn't oh please i
always like one that would go around in
a circle listen for a while there i
thought it was johnny [ __ ] pink
panther and i had the sponges that you
you washed the window down to create the
vacuum then you put the thing on the
thing to you know like when you shoot
those guns and they have yeah they press
to the window and you got to pull them
out so i put water and glass i would tap
it i'd cut the [ __ ] thing with glass
cutter i didn't even know what i was
doing i sweated my mother's grave is
this from movies or something i thought
that's how i thought i learned that a
friend of mine said yeah i'll teach you
we ended up breaking everything it
didn't break the window yeah we just
broke the [ __ ] window we had the
suction cups
and the whole thing what did you carry
you did like a briefcase a little bag no
like a little bag on our pockets we wear
hooded sweatshirts with like [ __ ] you
know i never i i can't lie to nobody and
say i was precision i was that position
i ended up breaking the glass and
putting my hand there you know and
sometimes we just had a window that was
open sometimes dog
i just pulled up on the door and kicked
that [ __ ] down like i owned it
like when i kidnapped bella and i went
to get the coke out of ella's house i
just kicked that door down
boom
[ __ ] when i walked out there were
people in the hallway i didn't worry
about that
didn't even give a [ __ ] i just put my
head down and kept walking
jesus
why am i gonna keep stop or look up just
walk out
how often do you get lucky the other way
because i made a huge mistake yesterday
what i did i didn't i was [ __ ]
elsewhere and i didn't roll my window
back up after i got my ticket at the gym
and i came out from the gym and my
window was just open
and i look i love the first thing i did
was i looked in the car on the ground
for shattered glass i thought i got
robbed
and i had forgotten to roll it up and i
had
a checkbook and my wallet in there i was
like [ __ ]
like luckily no one looked like how
often did you would you find stuff like
that like an unlocked car
nothing at all nah i was you know
i was
i didn't i didn't like [ __ ] dabbing
from people who were like
just in the car like i don't know okay
i didn't mind hitting drug dealers
because they were out there once you
start selling drugs you're out of
[ __ ] boundaries that's it you're out
of legal boundaries
that's it anything goes people are
allowed to shake you down people allowed
to take your drugs
that puts you somewhere you're in a
league where's the actual law
no it's not the actual law but it's like
the unwritten law yeah i see what you're
saying that's cool
it was very [ __ ] spontaneous i didn't
[ __ ] just walk by and go i'm gonna
break into this house
god knows excuse me if those people are
poor what the [ __ ] going on up there
so i didn't want to [ __ ] clip people
like that and then all that time you had
the gun
sometimes
yeah yeah i had a gun then
[ __ ] i always carry the gun then how
[ __ ] crazy is that i think in my life
now i would never carry a gun now
you know i have a gun but i would never
[ __ ] carry it
but just to think that i carried i'm
nine millimeter
how much [ __ ] trouble i gotta got
into lee and he never had one shootout
and one
hey
like i pulled the gun a couple you did
yeah how does that feel horrible really
scary
scary scariest things ever did pull a
gun on people because that's it again
you're in a different realm somebody's
got a gun on them
i got a gun on you lee
anything could [ __ ] happen now
that's a lot of pressure that's it
that's it anything that [ __ ] happened
oh my god once you pull a gun on
somebody oh my god it's the scariest
[ __ ] thing in the world no more
christmas card list no once you pull a
gun on somebody lee you
whether to rob them whether they pull
your like i used to put guns on coke
dealers
i used to like let guys know i had guns
that's like lift up your shirt yeah like
let [ __ ] people don't even think
about it i'll blast you right in the
[ __ ] i mean i was terribly terrible i
think you got all your movies from
acting for like movies since you love
movies so much i think you like got all
your moves
that's [ __ ] up
i got a lot of that [ __ ] too that's why
i wasn't that bad at that particular
i knew how to hide a gun the right way
because of one
you know i would never step father yeah
i would never put my gun in my [ __ ]
uh strap there i was always carried in
between my legs
i would always have like an ankle
holster no way yeah
i had a [ __ ] badass holster for a
while that's how crazy i got i had the
the don johnson holster with the gun
here and it would crisscross your back
no you wouldn't and you would have two
bullets so that was towards the emily
what would you think to yourself as
you're playing on in the morning you're
like yeah i'm a bad mother [ __ ] like
that's why you tweet all that stuff now
because you that's if i was putting on
like a holster oh my god i don't know
what my heart was thinking
thank god
somebody i really don't have an answer
for anybody if anybody ever sat me down
and questioned me yeah
what i was thinking in the morning when
i put the holster on
i was thinking today is the day i'm
gonna get killed
i was thinking today is the day that
somebody's gonna come
and get me for something i did in my
youth and i'm gonna have to pull this
gun and we're gonna shoot it out like i
was
and i used to go target practice and
then once every 10 days i used to clean
my gun
all the [ __ ] time yes lee you have to
keep your guns clean i used to take them
home spread the newspaper out and take
the brush and the [ __ ] things out
i was a [ __ ] idiot lee did you have
it when you had the rocky apartment
because that's just the image on my head
no by that time i was done with the
rocky apartment that was done okay
after i got arrested for the kidnapping
i came out i had a few guns
and little by little i got rid of them
one by one i still know where two of
them are in colorado and boulder
if they're even there if the place got
developed and torn down the guns got
found oh okay
i always have you would hide them places
yeah
yeah
if you go back would you ever consider
like going to check
just to like see or like somebody no i
don't want to even touch that energy
anymore
oh that would be crazy if that if they
were there oh my god i used to have the
i used to put the shoulder holster on
and go out at night with a jacket over
italy
and i wouldn't let people touch me i
just shake their hands a wave
[ __ ]
oh
god oh my
one night in like 19
i kidnapped vela in 87
but in 86 this is when i was really
losing it this is when i was really
losing it
this had to be october of
86. and by this time i was gonely i was
gone i was
i started i had stayed clean for about
16 months from december
of new year's eve 84 until about april
of 86 and i started dabbing a little bit
like a couple lines here a couple lines
there
i would get high with jackie's mother
and
we you know whatever watch tv or i eat
her ass whatever the [ __ ] we're into
and uh either one and then i just
started doing doing more and more blow
then danny b called me he was a podcast
and he said that he could get coke
really cheap and he was getting he was
they were making a ton of money him and
his partner at the time
because they were buying it directly
from these cubans for 800
an ounce it came out like i don't know
what like they were selling they were
buying like 11 ounce packages and that's
what they would sell me like instead of
selling it to me at first
and i had no money lee and i went to
these two guys
and i did the math and with the money i
was gonna make i could borrow money from
them and pay them interest okay and what
i would do is i would tell the people
get your money ready for today i'm
coming with some great coke and i knew
what everybody else was selling there
was like three or four other coke
dealers and i knew what they were
selling so i undercut them price wise i
had a better product and i had a better
presentation
i left the rock everybody was grinding
up coke then and cutting grinding it up
and giving it grinds up and people would
say well people like like that when they
go out people like it like that but you
give somebody a rocket coke when they
see it they lose their mind they come
back and buy more
so i was undercutting them on price five
dollars which made me lose money in a
way because nobody has a five on them so
everybody will always give me 40 and
hold me five
oh okay you're following me so unless
when you came the next time i go oh you
owe me five from the last time give me
the 50.
there's no ch you're following me so but
in the end i lost money for doing that i
should have just sold rocky coat for 50.
i could still cut it
but
and that's what i did so i always knew
that as soon as i get the ounces back
i'd sell it
on an amount i'd go to a guy like you
that i know you were buying from
somebody i was like oh wait buying for a
night what are you paying for an ounce
i'm paying 15. how about if i could sell
you blow for 12.
and better than what you i'd still throw
a cut on it
and i'd still make
400 an ounce at 12
right if i was paying eight for it yeah
so by the time i had to coke back in
colorado i had already sold half of it
so all my investors had their money
first
so the rest of the money was all profit
for me so in a way it was good because
it didn't then towards the end i kept
snorting more and more and more and more
and the more i started the more guns i
bought because i was buying guns to take
to the east coast and on the way back
i'd bring the coke
it was good this is craziness this is
[ __ ] great this is like a [ __ ]
horrible part of my life that at the
time i was doing it number one i was so
stupid
because i could have still been locked
up number two a thousand things could
have happened and in my mind lee i
wasn't doing nothing wrong i mean i was
traveling with 12 guns at a shot and a
suitcase with three sweatshirts with
boxes of bullets
boxes of bullets
and ten of those [ __ ] holsters
jesus i i've never done coke
but you said it makes you paranoid
how could you have so many guns and
never once shoot at anything well it
goes in cycles because
the first couple years i did blow i
didn't get paranoid
but i got you know it's a different you
go in cycles then after like three or
four four and a half years that's when i
started getting the paranoia i started
looking out the window
you know i would hear noises
you know by 86 i was gone i was hearing
noises and the paranoia was growing and
that's what made me buy more guns
and i i ca probably from mid-july
to november of 86
in aspen i had a gun on me all the time
maybe even two guns
i'd have one in the car under my seat or
under the passenger seat
and i'd have one on my body
but
the cops were watching me
but to rattle me in those days
they tried to either bug the house
so they broke into i had a i had a the
house i was house sitting at there was a
main house then there was a uh
a little house we kept the drugs in the
main house
the little house where i lived there was
no drugs the scale the drugs the baggies
everything was in the main house
because the main house they uh it was i
wasn't in that was supposed to be in
there
if you walked into the main house and
went down the stairs there was like a
little boiler room downstairs that
controlled the pool and everything that
they had right behind there there were
some places where i had the scale and i
weighed the coke
i weighed the coke i would lock myself
in that be hotter than [ __ ]
from the steam bath and everything i'd
hide all the coke in there
so i think the cops knew i was doing in
there so they tried to break into my
house one night i got back
and i could see the steps and i could
see that the door was fidgeted with
so i assumed it was a certain person
that's dead now his name is todd
and i knew that where he was going to be
at there was a party i'll never forget
this is how crazy i was i walked in the
party without a [ __ ] jacket
just holsters just the holster
the gun in and i took the gun out of the
car and walked in there with that in my
hand
and i said where's todd
and i grabbed him and
i got into a little bit of argument and
he swore to me it wasn't
he had known me for a long time and he
did
todd was a great kid i always loved todd
with all my heart
except for that one moment at wall i
didn't know but think about all the
things that could have happened what if
he would have pulled the gun oh my god
that's the what ifs what if i would have
walked in there when i was talking to
todd one of his buddies would have
pulled the gun and put it to my head and
i would have had that gun in my hand and
everybody's gone off and shot one of the
girls in the house these are all things
that i get up every morning
people always say man you're pretty
humble because i get up every morning
and i thank the [ __ ] lord
because i remember stories like that
that's what keeps me on my [ __ ] toes
late
[ __ ] like that i walked into that party
with 30 people
gentiles nothing to make it worsely
and as for todd whatever his [ __ ]
name was and said let me talk to this
[ __ ] with a gun in my hand and a
gun in the holster how much of a [ __ ]
puerto rican was i
pretty much oh my god that's
that's crazy
that's the [ __ ] that makes me [ __ ]
sick to my stomach oh my god
yeah let's do some [ __ ] shout outs
real quick well
you stream is down again no it's cool it
went down like twice but what do you
want to do people what the [ __ ] you want
me to do it's not even enough we're
getting off
oh [ __ ] do your thing
has somebody
how cool is it that we brought rita's
italian ice blast podcast
i'm so high right now just thinking ooh
look at the italian ice again
but i went there yesterday to take the
baby it was [ __ ] closed i didn't even
do the [ __ ] shout outs what the [ __ ]
am i doing
took my brandy lee you know i love you
brandon lin called me the other with the
call back didn't answer paul lynch
[ __ ] you're my man eddie cannani
peter garcia had been [ __ ] we've been
going back and forth
uh
i don't know what the [ __ ] that says
spiral tip is for you glenn paschemi
matthew seal and hash star i love you
[ __ ]
houston was great this weekend man
i had some nice food i stuck to my
[ __ ] points
i worked at the hotel an olympic bar on
a bench so i did all my [ __ ] my
deadlifts and everything i'm down to
three oh [ __ ] nine now hell yeah i've
lost 16 pounds so i'm feeling better
your clothes looser
yeah my clothes are loose i'm strong i
feel good i took the day off today
because i worked out
friday saturday and sunday i didn't go
to jiu jitsu today i just did something
this morning went to this audition so
everything felt really good this week
i'm in tempe the agostino's coming with
me oh [ __ ] it's gonna be [ __ ]
fun you know what i'm saying and what
day is thursday through saturday
thursday through [ __ ] saturday that's
awesome you know how we do it jackson
how much did you give me because this is
almost like give you does it really
matter it doesn't really [ __ ] matter
the the people at inner canada will put
420 on the rapper and i thought for a
second is a 420 milligram
star but it wasn't no you almost uh
you're almost looking at four [ __ ] 20
probably
uh what is that sadie i don't know
i'm pretty high myself well you don't
think you're [ __ ] special because
you're sitting there you put hash on the
on the pipe that had like
listen man what the [ __ ] was that
at 10 o'clock i went over to this place
on mentor that sells this [ __ ] this is a
gentile store where they're very nice
they have lemon water at the door
there's no russians working you know
there's just night there's a hindu with
a new haircut
right this little hindu dude who sits
there and all this [ __ ]
i got there at 10 after 10. i thought it
was going to be packed i got valet
parking
i walked in i got i walked in i got a
gram of regular weed indica that was
pretty good
i got a graham with a sticky that
chinese [ __ ] heroin the one-eyed jew
wasn't there he called in sick today
it's 4 20. and the jewish holiday it's a
jewish holiday and then i got a a piece
of that uh master kush hash
right and then on the way out they go
hold on we got a gift bag for you i got
a gift bag it's 4 20.
they gave me oh my god they gave me
hemp lotion
another big piece of hash another big
piece of that [ __ ] they gave me a vapor
pen
that you have to buy the vapor flavors
and just smoke it like the like the blue
cigarettes and [ __ ] like that okay they
gave me
uh
an edible
a 60 milligram metal which i popped
right there at 10 10.
right and they came back oh they gave me
kiva berries
in the bag i brought the bag to the car
and opened it up i'm like and then
before i left there was two dudes giving
away free samples
they gave me a banana
a little piece of banana chip but the
bag is just big 100 milligrams i have to
eat a bag of banana chips the guy's like
this is healthier go [ __ ] yourself
and there was a guy uh with brownies all
gluten free
no calorie diabetic [ __ ] brownies
that's what
it was a little piece but it was 25
milligrams so i inhaled that too so
right off the bat i had 85 milligrams
out of me on the walk out you see i'm
saying so who's better than me
but there's [ __ ] people everywhere at
these weed stores like what happens
today is the people give you free bags
so people go from store to store just
signing up getting [ __ ] the stamina
joints and it's not good [ __ ] that they
really give you but at least they make
an effort man cnn's doing this thing
right now about like the people who are
opening legal stores
in colorado and they made like something
like 50 000 their first day or something
and it's just like
if i had a little bit of money like why
why wouldn't you consider going out
there and buying a store
if you were one of the first i really
enjoy it
let let's get something out of the
[ __ ] way right right like on all the
evils i really enjoy marijuana i don't
know what is that i really do out of all
the evils whatever habit you may have
bad habit whether it's eating [ __ ]
mayonnaise whatever the [ __ ] we
whatever the [ __ ] are you thinking
but what i'm trying to say you like
mayonnaise i like well i'm not
mayonnaise out of a spoon you know i'm
rubbing it all over your body and
jumping up and down
[ __ ] juice
i'm just saying okay but what i'm trying
to [ __ ] tell you is that sorry out of
all the evils i really enjoyed marijuana
because for me this is day one this is
day one man i never dreamt the [ __ ]
smoking and what it lose you once you
smoke it you giggle you [ __ ] giggle
that's fine what who does not like
to laugh
who does who wants to be miserable a
[ __ ] day hitler especially laughing
at [ __ ] that makes no sense at all in
your world when you [ __ ] laugh
right
and then
i found it to be uh
by the time i was 17
i finally calmed me down and i found it
to open up my head if i had a problem i
was feeling bad about something
i would smoke it and it would help me
think out the problem
that's how i looked at it for all those
years but then it became something i
smoked when i went to bed
and it really helped me fall asleep hell
yeah and then it became something that i
smoked in the morning
just to
take the edge off the day whatever i was
thinking would consume me when i told
you i had anxiety i was [ __ ] blood
when i was 21. yeah that's when i
started smoking pot in the daytime heavy
duty because
it rolled out that
i wasn't that anxious anymore i was
always an anxious kid i could like if
you told me to be somewhere at eight i'd
get that 7 30 and [ __ ] sweat bullets
and be waiting for your [ __ ] you know
i didn't want to be that guy i didn't
like that feeling i didn't like being as
competitive as that was at little
dumb things you know there's some things
you could be competitive at but there's
some things you have to let live and let
live
and that's what pot took away from me so
that's why i enjoy it you know i get it
so for me to sell it at a store i could
really talk to people i really enjoyed
it it wouldn't be money for me it would
be something that i love to get high i
love to talk to people about it i love
to
wouldn't you want to have a store and
play music
all [ __ ] day i have a dj there just
so i play the [ __ ] music [ __ ] the dj
it sounds like fun but then again it's
also like
it's a great way to make like a millions
of dollars
which is like it's not a bad
side and listen i don't have
i have no
i have no ill will about somebody making
a million dollars off me i don't give a
[ __ ] if i buy something you know if you
want to that's what you want to do for a
living
and you don't go [ __ ] you know if you
don't give a [ __ ] about getting shot
again i i know for a fact one of these
weed stores gonna get robbed today
oh it's easy easy day today yeah they
got their guard down everything is high
they're giggling the chicks are giggling
i guarantee there's going to be three
wheat stores robbed today because three
knuckleheads are going to think you know
let's get them on 420. they've been
watching the store since 10 o'clock all
this money all this cash where the [ __ ]
is it going there's got to be somewhere
in there i like giving people bad ideas
no it's the [ __ ] truth what do you
think i got to give people bad ideas but
so every time you see a bank robbed
that's joey dears game the [ __ ] idea
well nothing every time you see somebody
[ __ ] uh punch a gas station attendant
now because i talk about the freaky
freddy story you're gonna feel but no no
no people follow the gas station listen
when i go to the sun so herbal they're
already trying to get robbed
[ __ ] they've been there maybe a half a
year there was a guy out there robbing
customers
[ __ ]
you know every [ __ ] store
that i bought weed at
has had somebody trying to [ __ ] be
johnny pirate that makes sense and i've
seen them i saw him at cushman in
hollywood when they were in the small
building i think somebody was on the
show and we were talking about cushmar
used to be in a small building an office
building right it was horrendously bad
you know they're in a building with
dentists the whole building smelled like
[ __ ] weed
somebody tried to rob them where they
were there at gunpoint all of them
and they got caught somebody tried to
rob cushman when they were on [ __ ]
sound but somebody tried to rob
the wheat store that was next to justin
uh fortune's [ __ ] gym
people always trying to rob those
[ __ ] things man there's no security
in there it's some [ __ ] guy that's
[ __ ] stoned with cameras you go in
there but see that's why they get the
ids and the cage like if you go to
hollywood they're [ __ ] tight
they're tight
you have to give them an id to go in so
they got your id
so unless you got a fake [ __ ] id that
means you got to go all the way and get
a fake id not have any fingerprints on
it because you got to have an id that's
why you don't run right into it like the
place that was on magnolia santana's
there was no all you had to do was buzz
you and they buzzed in you gave the kid
the the license at the county you're
[ __ ] he's getting robbed
he's getting robbed three [ __ ] guys
three grand bangers are gonna go in
there there's people that just go from
store to stall and check out the
security you have to
assume when somebody is a new [ __ ]
patient you have to assume they just
come in there that's what they do bro
how do you think places get robbedly
people see vulnerabilities it's like
anything else
people come into your store walk out and
go ooh
if i was a [ __ ] burglar i'd hit that
[ __ ] place they had reds money on the
register the back window was open
they don't buzz you at the door that's
how it starts
didn't they tell somebody who tells
somebody who tells somebody next thing
you know you're getting [ __ ] robbedly
that's [ __ ] up that is [ __ ] up not
as [ __ ] up as you all look at you what
do you got planned for tonight you're
going picking up paulie's something food
or what
no i don't know what i'm gonna do
um
let me [ __ ]
that's great i know i could i was just
thinking
like you know how you said like student
loans were low interest like if i was a
student now you should do that just take
a student loan out and just
buy a dispensary in colorado no you take
a couple student loans out and you buy a
house because even if the interest rate
is what you're still [ __ ] making
money it's three percent
okay you're following me so let's say
even if you juice the money out
even if somebody comes to you says leona
borrow fifty thousand [ __ ] no who are
you okay i'm gonna give you ten percent
a week
you're gonna give me ten percent of five
thousand dollars a [ __ ] week that's
500 [ __ ] bucks until the five
thousand dollars is [ __ ] paid off and
all
that's your investment right there
you know a lot of mobsters do that
like they won't like every let's say a
family right let's say like the gambinos
okay the gambinos had a chapter of just
dudes that loaned money
okay at 10 who do you lend money to a
bank that want uh
a business that doesn't want to borrow
from a bank they got credit and
everything but they just don't want to
go to a bank it's a short-term loan
50 000 maybe they want to buy some
inventory or something like that i come
to you and i go lee you're my captain
i got some money i want to push what can
you give it to me for you give it to me
for a point and a half
i loan it out for six
a lot of times when you get out of jail
the mobsters will give you fifty
thousand and give it to you for a half a
point
i don't know what that means a half a
point you have to give them a half a
point a week so what's fifty thousand
what's five points or fifteen what's ten
points to fifty thousand five what's
five point two fifty five thousand
twenty five hundred
and what's a point of fifty thousand
maybe like six hundred five hundred so
you give me 50 000
for a half a point a week
and i loan it out for five points a week
i make four points right off the [ __ ]
top
so if i lend you 50 000
for five points a week right right fifty
thousand ten thousand is five you're
gonna give me 2500 a week right until
you have my [ __ ] 50 000. plus
interest that's the interest okay you're
gonna give me 2500 a week do you have my
50 000 in full the 2500 you're giving me
a week is interest
ah i'm gonna give him 600. i made 19
right off the [ __ ] map by lending you
money
okay you're following me so that's why
all those type of loans when they're low
interest you could always do something
with it because you're gonna do it at
eight percent or nine percent of ten
percent not if you're landing money on
the street so you're like a middle man i
i feel you
sure you're a [ __ ] middle man and
you're still taking something right off
the top that'll be for your [ __ ]
damages that's crazy though to loan
someone else someone else's money
that's messed up what do you think a
bank does
one thing when you go buy a car okay
when you go buy a car tonight lisa goes
to volkswagen
and he says i want to buy a car they
take your credit app and they fax it out
there they do business with eight banks
they email it to eight banks six banks
are gonna come back
they're gonna try to get the best rate
right from the bank
so they're gonna be anywhere between
nine i don't know what the i don't know
what the national interest rate is so
please don't quote me on this when you
[ __ ] buy a car okay okay and you go
to finance department and you go in
there and you go hey
i got a an uh
i got a bank who says don't let me don't
give me a new car loan what's the
percentage
nine percent i gotta beat that
all right so i'm gonna take your credit
out i'm gonna send that [ __ ]
and then one bank comes back with seven
i'm gonna charge you eight
so i'm gonna make a point on this
[ __ ] loan
guess what a point hated a lot of money
but if i do ten of those a [ __ ] week
that adds up my friend so i have to get
the point i get the point because the
bank gave me the loan at seven percent
you said that if i could
beat [ __ ] 8.5 uh that you you do i'll
get your business i give you the [ __ ]
loan at eight percent and then they pay
you back i feel i just make a point
right there so if i do ten of those a
week
that's another way a a car a dealer
makes money
they deal with a couple different
[ __ ] banks they send your credit
application out
somebody buys you for six you just
commit it because you said 8.5
so i'm still gonna get you for eight i'm
not gonna drop under eight i got you
with eight if if i get you under eight
and a half yeah okay
i'm gonna make two points on you
you dig [ __ ] i feel you you learn
something everything i didn't know this
either
until i sold [ __ ] cars
it's all a scam
it's not all a scam people got to make a
[ __ ] living lisa yeah everybody's
gotta make a [ __ ] dollar somewhere
you know what i'm saying
i know but it seems like they're just
everyone's finding new ways to charge
people for stuff
well what do you do when you wake up in
the morning you don't want to charge
people you're going to work for free no
i don't want to go
i don't want to work for free
but
i i almost had to fly somewhere a couple
weekends ago why somebody fly somewhere
okay
and i spent all day at the airport
and i would have missed three
connections and i had a hotel booked at
a car rental booked
so that's a lot of money lost if i can't
get there right
the air report the airline does nothing
like it's hard to get to anyone on the
phone i spend hours in line waiting to
talk to somebody
but
if
i want to stay an extra hour i have to
pay 200 just even think about changing
my flight and now because tickets are
more expensive
i have to pay what the difference in the
fare is
i just it doesn't seem fair and you you
fly every week you must deal with it
constantly
it's a cost to do business
you got to fly
and that's why they can do it
you have to fly and they have you over a
barrel
you know you pay for the hotel room
ahead of time
that's your [ __ ] fault block cause
you're a momo you don't pay for that you
just make the reservation and you cancel
from the airport
and that's it you make the reservation
right they'll take your credit card
number but sums don't some of them don't
they just take the reservation then you
pay when you get there you give them
your credit card and they pay you bang
the hotel on the [ __ ] way out don't
you think that's smart at that second
right now he's trying to save money
right now so would you end up dropping
for that three bills yeah to be a
[ __ ] momo yeah
it's okay you're living your life you'll
never do it again no you'll never
[ __ ] do it again see that's how they
get you
they just swallowed 300 [ __ ] dollars
and they don't have the decency to say
we understand your situation and they
never even called that's a [ __ ] up
thing the hotel never called once i
called the airport when i thought i was
gonna be delayed once and then i was
like
first like they didn't even answer the
phone they like picked up but they're
like having a party
and then they like when they finally
picked up i was like i'm gonna be late
they're like okay
and i was like do you want my name or
anything like nah
we don't really care
so
who cares they're gonna swallow the
[ __ ] though a lot of you people at
home today thought
this was gonna be like a 420 [ __ ]
momo get-together smoke-a-thon
we ain't like that we got we wasn't our
home outside oh my god we smoked a bowl
outside we had a couple pieces of
[ __ ] edible juice there's a couple
pieces of apple i can't even help myself
this is a new star that we cracked into
panicky edibles always throwing [ __ ]
heat
representing always like we took the one
[ __ ] star it's not uh what's that
song
twinkle twinkle it's not you can't sing
the [ __ ] song for this star no more
plus we ate buck 25 outside plus i ate a
whole [ __ ] chiva chew a buck 80. we
think you're dealing with people you
know what i'm saying i've been living
for a [ __ ] 20 for the last 30 years
get your clock fixed [ __ ]
what's up lisa yeah
this is a very long but a great shirt
what i've been living 420 for 20 years
look at your clock face yeah that's your
[ __ ] clock's face it's a great that's
a great
till 420 moves out here ralphie may told
me it's 4 20 i don't even know
who waits till 4 o'clock to smoke dope
anyway only some [ __ ] and my world is
[ __ ] 6 30 a.m
6 20.
that's the time i was smoking this
morning
i got [ __ ] up this morning that's why
i went back to that place to get more of
that [ __ ] chinese glass
heroin opium we got you smoking this
afternoon which was delicious i know you
enjoyed it don't [ __ ] me and people
out there like
like to smoke and they they make fun of
me for getting this high
when you say you were smoking at 6 20 in
the morning you weren't smoking like a
light joint like to just get the day
started
i'll talk step lightly you probably put
hash on there everything like the
audition was at one though oh my god i
had a right i had to go right so i
wanted just to be nice and big so i got
up early i did some writing i got on
facebook
i [ __ ] had a nice breakfast i went
for a nice walk i came back and i got
chiseled well hold my line i got sizzled
before the walk i can't line nobody
i got [ __ ] up to the gills before the
walk i came back and i got [ __ ] up
again i went and wrote for two hours i
went over my audition then i shot down
this [ __ ] uh
i came to a couple weed stores and i
came to see my main man lisa and some of
the beautiful people in the church or
what's happening now what the [ __ ] you
want from me god sucked that sounds like
a good job you have a guest today
because what's the [ __ ] difference
it's 4 20. i didn't want to mess around
ask somebody questions maybe they don't
want to smoke pot or whatever the [ __ ]
they are so [ __ ] the guests today we'll
resume them again with guests on [ __ ]
wednesday then next week we're doing
three podcasts for you next week
yeah i can't feel my lips we got super
secret [ __ ] guess look at this
[ __ ] guy can't feel his lips you're
like a hooker at five in the morning she
can't feel the lips because you're
[ __ ] 18 dicks what are you going to
do you know this week tempe arizona i'm
very excited i haven't been last time i
was in tempe was with the flying jew he
went to the fights this weekend what are
you waiting for what do you want me i
don't know what are you wearing what's
the matter with you you're all right
i love this [ __ ] kid no look at him
what do you got planned for the week
oh just a lot of work
but i'm consulting you like this console
i mean look let's face it you know a lot
about podcasts
you know a lot about that i was talking
about matt coleman from the improvs
today and i i was talking to him about
marketing we were talking about comics
and what comics are doing and what he
finds he he hires facebook ads and
everything
and i was saying guys i know nothing
about marketing i'm not going to sit
here and tell you i know dick about
nothing whatever you guys learned at
school for four years i can't tell you i
don't know
but i've learned something completely
different the last four years i know i
have you know and so have you you've
seen trends
you know when when i was doing viewing
to be she released on friday who the
[ __ ] downloads on friday and by monday
bill burke comes along [ __ ] joey diaz
yeah you know there's so many little
things
that enhance your podcast it's like when
you go to jiu jitsu and you learn to
move and somebody comes and says put
your knee
uh closer to the ear for side control or
when you do the camorra put your knee
you know this just
put your hand
on by his ear or your elbow that's what
it is the elbow by his ear when you're
pressing down
they just help you they just enhance you
you know there's a lot of people that
are starting a podcast right now
and you're hey it's like anything else
in life you know how do you start
standing up counter you see somebody on
stage and you say i'm funny in him how
do you get into fighting you look at
somebody that's fighting you i can beat
his [ __ ] ass same thing happens with
podcasting there's a lot of people
probably listen to this podcast and i
could probably do a [ __ ] better job
and you sit down and you get you get the
equipment or what you think works and
guess what once you
process okay what lee provides is just
letting people know what things to get
it's like nan attack when we were
talking to them and they told us to get
we wanted to get a set of cameras and
they told us to get different sets of
cameras these are the things we learned
what would have happened if you were the
other cameras
they wouldn't work for this okay so
there's so many little things that you
learn about you it's like if i if if uh
if my toilet [ __ ] clogs up we all
know how to decline a toilet how to get
a snake and do it whatever the [ __ ] it
is i don't know but after a while you
know what man there might be something
that somebody might come in for the 50
bucks and just do and take care one time
it won't happen again
that's the things we've learned and
that's the things i've learned through
the podcast like when not to release
what to talk about with subjects not to
[ __ ] talk about you know what type of
people to bring on to interview you know
like when you're uh when you're looking
at somebody there's a lot of people i
can bring on the [ __ ] show but i'll
tell you man i i talk to them in public
and i don't think we'll [ __ ] jizz so
why would i bring him on the [ __ ]
show and insult you guys
these are the moves you learn instead of
just you know i bump into a thousand
[ __ ] people a day i bump into a
thousand people a week that i could go
up to and go hey man how about the
podcast a lot of people just gonna be a
pain in the ass they're not gonna show
or they're gonna tell me they want to do
it in the last minute their mother died
or the cat got hit by a [ __ ]
lawnmower or some [ __ ]
so [ __ ] it yeah
i just know what people are gonna work
out so sometimes i'd rather put you know
i'd rather put somebody on that
relationship on
than just some [ __ ] guy that you know
i bump into on the street that's been in
a band or something like that
that i may know him from his music but i
don't really [ __ ] know who he is
i'd rather not even bring him on here
because i don't know him i'm not going
to get the best out of them for you you
know what i'm saying right what's up
lisa no so i like what you're doing i
like the service you're providing i
believe in it you know i hope that if
you're thinking of starting a podcast
you contact the flying jew and yeah
thank you
asking for advice
and it's just
i did a little research like when i was
thinking about doing it like i thought
about doing it for a little bit and then
some guy actually
tweeted at me and said maybe i should
like write a a book but
i like i when i typed in podcast
consultant there's tons of them there's
all the podcast gurus and
and
and king of podcasts
but but do they have a podcast well
that's that that's the thing
i'm not gonna be i'm not the best audio
guy i'm i i feel like i get good audio
but i don't know everything that i
should right we still get people put the
compressor up like that who gives a [ __ ]
go deaf but i i have a basic knowledge
of it
but i have
hundreds and thousands of hours
of just like i learned i tried new mics
this weekend they didn't work i now i do
have to return them
but it's just
i didn't realize until today when i did
my first one how much like it takes a
lot there's a lot of steps and it's
still so new that there's not really a
a guy to follow
so like i just
i just thought it'd be cool if like i i
don't know how many individual people
are gonna start them that's that's great
if you want to
but like i'm thinking about trying to do
like businesses
or uh like tv shows as like marketing
tools
because it's such a inexpensive way to
well this is what the podcast is right
it's a marketing tool for people who you
have three different departments you hit
with this you get the person who wants
to express themselves and what they
really think i always thought that this
would enhance my career in the sense of
these people know where i was [ __ ]
coming from they wouldn't just judge me
from the stage or whatever stories i
heard you know little stories go around
two yeah you want to market yourself you
want to help to get out there as a tv
show it would be [ __ ] great to talk
about what you want you know there's
people like me that are nerd
those little [ __ ] things about tv you
even watch pop-up on amc they have like
a move like like let's say they're gonna
put on
under siege that that the name of the
steven sagamore when he takes over the
ship sure is that it i
then they have a six o'clock and then
eight o'clock the eight o'clock is just
a movie but the six o'clock is the
director's cut with uh with little
pop-ups
when steven seagal did this scene he
broke his rib he couldn't shoot for
three weeks you know when uh they hired
her they really wanted what's her name
but she fell on the last moment and they
hired this girl i like those tidbits
about a movie if you're a movie buff
yeah you know that's what i think would
help if like they did one with sons
anakin it was horrifically bad afterward
i don't want to see
watch his son's anarchy what i want to
do is watch the tv show
wednesday night and get in my car
thursday morning and as i'm driving to
work here commentary yeah on the show i
seen or at the end of the film
this is what i like at the end of the
film a movie like last week paul block
got released right
right so if you want to see paul blart
on the way out somebody gives you a
little card that says if you want to
hear commentary listen to the lowe's
movie commentary
list and they'll talk about that movie
the other movie that came out about the
chick that's 2 000 years old and
everybody saw her
a disney movie that came out this week
and then another
one about
finger upper ass
was it a prosthetic whatever the [ __ ]
happened you know what i'm saying and
then i
i hope i don't get any more work but the
fact to me
the fact that that all comedy clubs
don't have a podcast
that's not only that they'd have it but
that
like sometimes they'll cut like i've
heard stories of you going and you're
doing it while you're there
that's that's the stupidest
thing in the world if if i owned a
comedy club
all these communities are doing podcasts
have you call in a week before
and and people will listen to a comedy
club's podcast because they should be
having good comics coming in
the fact that they do it while you're
there defeats the purpose i know
well this is where your consulting
[ __ ] firm comes in [ __ ] up don't
tell me we'll see i know the [ __ ]
deal don't be bothering me give a shout
out to some sponsors here
honey.com optimum
optimization to the [ __ ] fullest i
got a big box from them last week i want
to thank orlando rios and i'll tell you
what their products are [ __ ] better
than ever that shroom tech is on fire
last week and they get me through those
two workouts uh friday and saturday and
sunday up there in [ __ ] houston the
one i did yesterday uh shroom tech is
tremendous man [ __ ] really is i
really am in love with that product do
me a favor go look at that product and
all the other products they have go to
honor.com if you see anything you like
go to the box and press in church church
c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 percent off your
present order on it you're going to
[ __ ] love the products they have i
can't do you anything for the battle
ropes and the kettlebells but i can help
you out when it comes to supplements
again go to hana go to the box and press
in church
c-h-u-r-c-h my favorite [ __ ] in
the world dave foley over at iron dragon
tv classic martial art films i mean
classic [ __ ] [ __ ] on there i took a
look again there's too many to [ __ ]
remember why am i why am i gonna blow
smoke up your ass do me a favor go to
iron dragon tv right now
take a look around go look around
they're that leader in 4k technology
they got great a lot by a lot he adds
more movies every week i can't wait till
he adds like westerns and [ __ ]
shoot em ups and criminal stuff do me a
favor why are you listening to a fat
[ __ ] like me go to iron dragon tv
see you're gonna get two movies for free
two movies for free on the [ __ ] arm
so go there go to the box and press in
joey joey j-o-e-y and get two free
movies two free films today you get them
this weekend you got nothing to do the
kids are going to go to your
grandmothers you want to get your dick
sucked you watch your pawn then later on
after you get your dick sucked you want
a little classic martial arts iron
dragon tv
is going to solve it for you not to
mention pretty soon we're going to start
doing commentary for them so if you go
to iron dragon tv i'm going to give you
a movie of the week a movie of the month
something i'm going to start that soon
all right so go to iron dragon and press
in julie there you go nailed the life
you vapor head [ __ ]
porch smoking [ __ ] suckers before you
see the devil it all starts at
netherlife.com
the best vaper put on the market not
only that they have tools to help you
dab if you're into the dabbing [ __ ]
technology go to life dot com see what
they got let's say you open up with the
vapor pen it's a fifty dollar value what
do they get it for twenty percent twenty
percent of that means forty your [ __ ]
math is all [ __ ] up today what kind of
jew i hang out with doesn't matter man
you can't give me a favor the math i
know is the 400 milligrams but also he
starts making 400 it's at least two or
three and a 20 stop and 125 that's 150
in my life
let's go
hello all right then shut the [ __ ] up go
to naildonlight.com and press enter
ideas boom and get twenty percent off
your first thought on the best vape on
the market number three who the [ __ ] are
you kidding i don't go nowhere without
my hitty cig whether it's the [ __ ]
tobacco or the cigarette 1200 guaranteed
puffs you could switch up on flavors if
you smoked a cigarette but with the
tobacco it's just
a cigar [ __ ] tobacco what's wrong
with it with the cigar it's just a
beautiful cigar taste you could take it
to las vegas and blow smoke in people's
faces different places you don't have to
[ __ ] light up if you think of the
quitting smoke and hidey sigs is the
company for you because it starts at 24
milligrams and goes all the way down to
zero if you just want to [ __ ] not
smoke and do something different hit
86.com guaranteed 1200 puffs per [ __ ]
piece flavor you could do whatever you
want but don't believe me go to
hittiesticks.com right now look at the
webpage find something that you want to
[ __ ] try and press in joey's shirt
and get 20 off your first daughter did
we say it was joey diaz for nailed the
life yeah ideas for now that life joey's
church thank you for confusing the
[ __ ] homebody ask me after i'm
pitching this one so anything what are
you pressing
there you go and get 20 percent off your
first order with 86 proven guaranteed
1200 [ __ ] bucks when you go to one of
these [ __ ] vapor stores you pay 10
bucks and the thing dries out after one
day these [ __ ] 1200 buffs
[ __ ]
so that's it that's your 4 20 edition i
hope you smoke and giggle and jump up
and down but what's the views that's
what we do every day you think i'm just
going to do this [ __ ] once a day like
new year's go [ __ ] yourself i smoke
every
day years of us every day i'm part of
the culture baby this is the culture you
know why because it keeps me
[ __ ] sane
i get it together i get focused when i
[ __ ] go over my lines i get focused
my comprehension gets better and this is
nothing that the government knows this
that helps me [ __ ] the government they
just think they got these scientists
doing this
i'm telling you we're works for uncle
joey okay same thing they say oh if you
have pain put that [ __ ] on there don't
numb the pain if you smoke pot it will
get your mind somewhere else and you
forget about the pain that's what the
weed does beside that i want to thank my
main man lee syed i want to thank
honor.com iron dragon tv
nailed it life.com and my main man over
at 86.com
please support these people they support
us
i want to thank my main man lisa and i
want to thank you guys uh the guys that
came out to houston i love you and for
you [ __ ] i'm going to see in
tempe
we're going deep this [ __ ] weekend
you understand me catchy agastino high
the agostino will get high he got high
one time and he puked and he pulled over
again banana bread he almost had a
[ __ ] you started him off with banana
bread
oh that's evil
he was at one of the clubs and it was
there
and he goes let me pick it up and uh
that's what happens all right we'll be
back wednesday four o'clock i love you
guys thank you very much for uh watching
the church today stay black and stay
beautiful this is one of my oldies i'm
gonna play for you guys right now
this is uh taking care of i used to
listen to this before i used to go to
englishtown new jersey there used to be
a converse place i used to stitch up
converse sneakers i used to go down
there listen to this and jump out and
jump in the dumpster and take out a
regular [ __ ] sneakers name of the
song is taking care of [ __ ]
business
hey that week
should i do the ends get through the
[ __ ] ass okay
yeah you got crazy when that song came
on [ __ ] yeah that's my jam brother
that's old school
go to honda.com and use cowork church
to get 10 off of your order of all the
grape optimization products
go to irondragontv.com and use cardboard
joey to get two free movie rentals of
all the great martial arts martial arts
movies
go to
uh nailed it life.com for all the oil
and wax smokers out there for the
premier vapor pen on the market you just
cover joey diaz to get 20 off and go to
hit esigs.com and use codeword joey's
church to get 20 off of your order
better tasting longer lasting proof is
in the vape with e-cigarettes and
e-cigars